e aí
hoje eu quero falar com você sobre algo
tradicional todos os presos professores
da cidade
eu quero falar contigo sobre o jogo
e aí
o olá pessoal problema algumas muito
dessa i
a pesquisar depois eu já estou o caso
[Música]
para se dizer eu estou relação brasil
o vídeo da música o jogo buscar de fogo
profissional vai precisar utilizar para
pessoas falsas
o jogo de motivar atividade susana i
e agora tudo mal até os dias de hoje
[Música]
gostoso como é que pode youtube 21
e aí
oi princesa não vou falar pra vocês
sobre a polícia o parafuso o
eu vou o pouco tempo
o mistério de animais que é preciso de
capturar jogo um pouco tempo
se você já é
o rabo
e a partir do povo aprendeu essa casa
jogo alegria principalmente des
o tempo
o principal precisamos marcar de fogo
burro mesmo tempo óculos e para começar
a
oi google
a cidade de meca no mesmo lugar está
indo embora amor fala aí na sua casa
sozinho e
eu não vou fazer nada não
e aí
e olha o funcionário público
e vamos amarrar de hoje eu queria saber
o
bom vamos lá
e aí
a usar roupas justas
eu não consigo assisti-los
eu faço a ouvir-me
a contar vai ter mais um
no vídeo de hoje é
e aí
bom dia pé bom
oi haha
olá meu nome é rodrigo a
o jogo do amor
é preciso dizer que eu sou burra
e nós amiga
a aula de churros jogador 1
o sobrevivente filme prova de fogo 100
da terra alguns f1
a fabricante de chips para pegar meu
celular o nosso calendário 201
é usado
a ficção precise referência e
a ligar para fazer hoje é
e aí
o jogo
a praia é
a barbie barbie girl
a árvore de natal nada para fazer não
e aí
a usar água durante ah
se você falar com ele trabalha domingo
o desafio foi colocado em
e aí
eu procuro
é para ir para lá
e não tem que fazer isso diversas vezes
ouvimos o tempo no treino simples fato
de não saber tocar tocar tocar policial
e
e aí
eu posso dizer
e esse já 201
os jogos de
e aí
o ok google jogo carregar vendidos
oi fala comigo
e aí
ah mas eu quero fazer um
eu não vou fazer um
[Aplausos]